all right welcome to the first session
of the second day of NC portal I hope
you had great dinner yes yesterday and
today I'm going to talk about common
mistakes in EF core and this talk is
going to be focused on some of the
common mistakes that I have seen in
production a couple of horror stories
uh that I have experienced as trying to
uh fix some of the applications where
the main takeaway from the developers
was EFC is horrible and then I looked at
it spend an hour on it things started to
run 100 times faster and it's like how
did you do that and I was like I just
did do these few things you know how you
do SQL queries if you think a little bit
in in that regard you can do really good
queres so this are a few things that I'm
going to show you as well as very e
course and net specific
things so first off I am Yan kova
originally from Slovenia now living in
Australia but you can call me
JK and you can uh follow me on all of
these socials I'm also a host at uh
global AI the podcast and several
different uh Australian and Brisbane uh
user groups I'm predominantly a net and
EF core developer um specializing in uh
building web
applications uh console applications and
whatever the clients need me to build uh
but I'm also a Microsoft AI MVP and I do
lots of chat GPT so if anyone here is to
have one good advice on CH GPT you're
covered all right so let's go into intro
then I'll uh go for the seven deadly
senses the the seven things that I seen
most commonly in production and has big
impacts on uh how your application runs
and a couple of many best practices
because I just doesn't don't want to
give you hey here some common issues
here's how to fix them but also here are
some really good advice that you
probably should
follow all right so one thing that you
might all of you know
is uh there are a lot of databases
nowadays and for anyone who's not too
familiar with ef core um one of the
reasons why you might want to use EF
core is because it don't always want to
decide which uh database you want to go
for and it kind of alleviates that
decision because you can start
developing the application with DF core
and decide later what specific database
engine you want to
use and there's also various orms
there's just couple of over here like EF
Dapper is technically a SQL builder plus
mapper uh then we have Mar and Cosmos DB
and there's lots more of them um but the
main reason why I usually choose EFC and
why I uh recommend people to use EF core
as one of the first
options is because it gives you a great
balance between features flexibility and
performance and it's one of the orms
that gives you the most choice between
these uh three options so if you need
more performance there is a way to
increase performance if you need more
flexibility you have an option to have
more flexibility usually it comes at the
cost of the other
two and it's really really awesome for
relational databases so if your database
is relational um EF core if you're doing
uh net is really awesome
for non relational EF core is getting
better and better and I'm seeing more
people now using EF core for
non-relational as well especially with
ef core
8 and one of the big things is the
builtin migration and DB scaffolding
along with other tools
because how many of you are doing uh
database
migrations quite a lot for how many
database migration are
painful okay pretty good crowd usually
for a lot of people database migrations
is a big pain and with ef core it's
usually just one command line you check
that everything is fine and just run the
migration and DB scaffolding if you need
to use the existing database there's a
CLI command where can just generate the
entire efco context for you you make
just a couple of tweaks and you
done and another thing if you have seen
yesterday's keynote what EF Co also uh
pretty nicely represents is the theory
of corop uh Cooperative principles um
basically what that means is when you uh
want to have a cult for instance that
concisely message what it wants to do
does only what you ask it to do uh and
various other things if you're more
interested in this Eli done a talk about
uh Lang language games and I really
recommend this because adopting these
principles I think will make you a
better developer in terms of how youve
write the code and how it's understood
by other
people all
right so the main part of this talk is
to avoid pain that sometimes come with
ef core so how many of you have
developed EF core and you had some pain
with
it that's quite a like half of the room
well hopefully I'm going to show you how
not to have that pain how to actually
enjoy
Eco um one of the things is I've seen a
lot of really badly written EF in terms
of here's 200 lines uh query and you're
like what does it do that's like I don't
know um then I'm going to Benchmark the
uh the uh queries because a lot of
people don't understand what um impact
certain lines of code may have and I'm
going to show you not just by running
the uh the code once I'm going to load
test it so I can show you the
consequences of certain uh certain
pattern when the server is already on
the load because your SQL Server as well
as your net server might behave
differently on the load than when you
just run it
once and lastly the horrors I have
seen and you will be able to do this on
your own if you like to because I'm
using
benchmark.us and time differences and
bomb Ander for load testing now now this
is not the best way to do load testing
as overall application load testing but
it's really good way to basically test
how a single endpoint behaves with or
without
load and also just for reference this is
my uh uh machine just so that you if you
get really different
numbers that might be one of the reasons
uh RAM actually uh will have a big
impact on performance so if you don't
have enough RAM you may get vastly
different uh results than I have and
most of the tests are done with Net 7 EF
core uh I haven't updated yet to EF core
8 but I have ran the test to verify that
uh the things that I'm talking to here
is still
reant relevant with ef core
and the test data is 7 million sales so
we have a table with 7 million records
54 products with don't use 23 employees
and 20,000 customers and this is
important because sometimes what happens
in production is your application runs
really really well really smoothly 3
months later everything is on
fire and this is why I'm took 7 million
sales to show show you that
fire all right seven nly scenes so first
off I carable to I inumerable I'll show
you this is one of the
biggest performance and stability issues
you'll
encounter uh then as not tracking uh
it's really good uh explicit joins so
how many of you are doing joins manually
like you've write the actual code not
many
okay uh getting all of the columns no
pagination that is something that when
it happens in production it slows down
your server considerably if not done
properly uh non-cancellable queries and
inefficient updates and deletes which
will uh which came with ef course
7 just went one second over there
uh I'll will also provide the slides uh
later all right so first
off how bad can uh can it be right
writing a little bit of bad code here or
there or uh just doing um efco without
thinking about what actually might
happen this is usually a question you
never want to ask or at least you never
want the answer to and I'm going to show
you why
iable to I inumerable
so here we have one code and some of you
may spot the problem here right
away and then we have
this this a little bit different code
right some of you might spot something
out over
here and then we have this code this is
something that they have seen very
commonly uh on a lot of client uh
projects
so what do they have all in
common technically they're all the
same so this one that does two list and
then count is technically the same as
this
one this is will get all of your data
from the uh
table and the reason why this happens is
when we do an HTTP request and at the
moment we we are uh casting it to I
inumerable what happens in EFC end is
says Ah we casting to I inumerable I'll
evaluate everything up to that point
which in this case means a select stuff
from sales that means it will get all 7
million records with all of the
columns uh from the database then it's
going to pass all of the data in its
full Lory only to check how many of them
are there and then it's going to dispose
all of the data never actually looking
into
it so what you should be doing is you
should always use I variable now this
particular case we have a private method
in used inside a service or command
query or uh wherever you would uh want
to use that I have seen where developers
try to be uh following good practices
use inumerable whereever they can and
they use uh I inumerable in Services
where they should be actually using I
quable now if you use clean architecture
you might actually have different
methods to avoid this
issue and what happens behind the scenes
is you can see here we have a full
statement we have sales. count and efco
evaluates the whole query with the count
and then
generates select count staff from
sales which then sorry which then only
returns a single integer that's it
doesn't return 7 million records just a
single
integer so what is if there's anything
that you remember from this St talk is
this part but don't worry we get for
anyone getting bought we're getting to a
more fun part
soon
benchmarks so the first
one was about million times took million
times more memory just imagine just
counting how many uh rows we have in a
table taks about 2 GB
FR on net side not on SQL service
side and it's 64 times slower and yeah
it's about three uh 3 and a half seconds
slow uh uh slower so that's a really
huge impact and keep in mind in couple
of years you might not have 7 million uh
sales you might have 10 15 35 Millions
this is going to skip scale this is
going to be bigger and bigger
problem and if your manager says well
users can wait three and a half
seconds this is why we have low
tests though because this is a very
small load but under very small load
those 3 and 1 half seconds now become 33
seconds with the same data we just put a
little load on
it whereas if we do it properly with the
uh I variable it stays 130
milliseconds so now we are having a
difference of
260 times faster and this is sometimes
the cost of not understanding what
happens behind the scenes and then say
well it sucks because it doesn't work
well
uh but also another uh thing here
is after run this test my computer was
unresponsive for 10 minutes and this
test only ran 16 seconds so 60 seconds
was enough that I wasn't able to move my
mouse for 10 minutes just to give you a
perspective of how bad this
is to be frank I did Run net and SQL
server on the same machine but
still now the other one uh that some of
you might not know how many of you know
asot
tracking a lot awesome so I'll just
quickly skip through because some of you
might know quite a lot uh about
EF so asot tracking basically what
allows you to do is it allows you to not
track changes and why this is important
is think of it I would almost prefer
that this would be called as read only
because that what effectively uh you get
is data from the database that is read
only uh and that the consequence of that
is by default when we are get fetching
data from the
database we generating the query we get
the SQL Server to respond back the data
we pass we map the data in EF core uh
and then EF core adds additional
properties to track uh all of your
columns and all of your rows so when you
do save changes it knows what changed
and with the as not
tracking that doesn't happen so whatever
changes you do it's not um when you do
save changes uh they won't be
saved
now the result of that is you get four
times less memory usage in this
particular case this is going to vary a
lot in some of cases it's going to be
20% in some of the cases is going to be
way more than that um but on average I
found about 50% less memory usage and
also about 50% faster on average from
the testing I
did and what is very important here is
this is very dependent on the DB
provider you use so at least in EF
course 7 and I think that was a bug um
asot tracking had no effect so if you
used asot tracking or not you got the
same
numbers and when we start to load test
we're getting about same performance
gain so that's mostly because with this
kind of load testing we're not
overloading the system enough where this
code would run significantly faster than
this one usually when you have big
disparity between the unoptimized and
optimized code is because the
unoptimized overuse so much resources
that the system is not able to keep up
giving and destroying the resources
and for explicit includes how many use
do
include nice almost the entire
room should have prepared a much more
advanced
talk uh so basically they are
um when you use that
include what that allows you to do is
just uh do a a join behind the
scenes and but there are a few issues
with do
include so if you do do
include but you're no longer need that
in the mappings you're not using this
custom anymore it will still do a join
to that table so some of you may know
that joins in SQL can be very expensive
and now you doing a join and you do
nothing with it so this is why uh
explicit includes
can be um many times quite problematic
sometimes they're necessary especially
if you need to track it and then save it
but if you can try to avoid it so for
instance here I have one that has dot
include and here I have one that does uh
mapping over here and you can see that
you can just directly map x. sales.
first name and what it's going to do
behind the scenes is it's going to uh
join the table sales and the
salesperson for you you don't have to
think about it and the advantage here is
if you no longer need these two
lines the that uh join no longer exist
that join only exists if you use it and
this this is the difference so if I
would put uh do include excels persons
here it will do join uh join no matter
what and of course you can use other uh
uh libraries like ult mappa to do the
mapping uh I usually like to do it
manually just because it gives you a
really good view on what data you're
fetching and everyone can look at the
code and understand ah okay we're
getting sales with salesperson and all
of this data is that we need for
whatever uh we're going to do with this
data
and here uh again the performance is
going to uh vary uh significantly
between one and the other queries how
complex the joints are but generally
speaking you will almost always get a
little bit faster performance if you do
manual projections especially if you
skip couple of
columns then we have common pagination
issues now how many of you are confident
that you know how to do
pagination okay we have only four hands
okay I'm not too surprised because this
is one of the things where I commonly
saw as like s you know you did the right
steps you just flip them a little bit
wrong and what usually happens is
you know they fetching all of the data
with the uh with the filter they need to
apply and I was like why they doing
that because they're trying to count uh
the entire how how many items there
are and then they apply uh pagination in
memory now if you have a few 100 or few
thousand rows you know you probably
won't bother with the performance s it's
it works fine with 7 million
records this is
horrible and this is why software gets
slower over time is because of small
things like this it's what they call uh
um death by million
Cuts instead what you can do is you can
use iable over here and even though it
feels a little bit wrong to do
to ask SQL Server hey give me a account
for this and then do pagination on the
the original query and then get the
results back but it turns out this is
almost consistently faster even on a
smaller uh size um uh uh smaller results
now if you have under the page you can
do a little bit more
optimizations like you don't need to do
uh um pagination if the count is less
than page size and stuff like that you
can squeeze out a little bit more
performance out of this but generally
speaking this is uh a pattern that you
can use for most of the pagination um
problems now you have another one some
of you might know is the cursor index in
SQL which is great for infinite
scrolling and is one of the most
performing rates uh for paginations um
but usually when you have
paged um
paged list uh sorry paged tables um they
don't work really well because the way
it works is you need to know the last
item from the previous page but if the
table can change over time or somebody
can just modify the number of page they
are on um it just doesn't work
anymore um because it's really tightly
connected to how you order in the
database and knowing what was the last
item from the previous
page but in most of the cases this is
good enough performance for most of the
cases but if you really need even more
there's cursor
index and this of course massive
performance differences uh obviously and
also here um because I didn't want to
wait for my machine to be available for
the next 10 uh unavailable for the next
10 minutes uh this is a smaller size
that this is not 7 million I think it
was uh 50,000 or something in that ballp
Park and you can see it struggled a lot
but when we implemented pagination uh
properly uh we were under 100
milliseconds which is really
good all right now this one I think a
lot of people did not know
either who knows uh cancellation
tokens who actually used
them okay but okay almost entire room
for knowing them and half a room are
using them how many of you are using it
for EF
core about the quarter okay I think I'll
make you use more often in EF as well
so what's the
problem well let's say somebody Doss you
for whatever reason or you have just
cranky users that smashes F5 a lot or
you get a lot of say your business
becomes really popular and you get lots
of requests what may happen is we get
here HTTP request EF C does its thing
send a query to SQL
server but then you have here a cancel
request now this cancer request can
actually happen if you have like an
angular application a SP application and
you switch from one page to another and
the user just switched from the page
away before the request finished so this
can happen more frequently than you may
think but what happens is this is still
happening behind the
scenes and not just that um it looks is
it is it cancelled well okay no just do
the thing normally but if it is
cancelled it will process your code
until the first cancellation token it
will hit or it will basically complete
the entire request and then ip.net cor
will be like you know what I actually
don't need your response and then just
discard your response so basically you
done all of this work for nothing
and if you under attack or you you're
basically having lots of reports that
takes 30 seconds to generate and uh a
manager is very cranky and uh smashes
refresh button lots of times you're
going to have bad time and SQL Server is
going to have a bad time as
well so what you can do is on all of the
request you can do canellation uh token
and then pass it over here in two list
Asing to First of default Asing uh any
Asing Max ASN almost all of the
operations that return something from uh
SQL Server will have an acing uh uh
option with a constellation
token now what happens is when we're
doing hdp request it generates a SQL
Server um query it uh sends it to SQL
Server the user cancels request we have
here uh a request to cancel um the SQL
query and that gets sent to the SQL
server and SQL Server stops and also the
ip.net core stops it's th a I think a
task canell uh exception and it it stops
uh from where you actually done the
query so the the exception bubbles up
and you then stop uh processing uh all
of uh the
request and the benefit of this is for
instance here we have we have a
similar uh test here where we just tried
to count and if I remember uh from the
first example the count was about 130
milliseconds or something like that
was much much faster than 10 seconds and
this is what happens when we do the same
request on the load where we cancel uh
the request uh every second so I think
i' actually done
this uh yeah I actually use the bad
example where it takes 3.5 seconds sorry
um just to make it so that it takes more
than one second to complete
now when we using cancellation tokens
what you might notice is it's only half
it should have been 3 and a half seconds
roughly from the first
example and it's still not 3 and a half
seconds and that's because when we do
canellation there's still some cleanup
to do there still the survey is still
overloaded with data like in in this
case I'm doing 12
requests um in parallel whereas in all
of the other test it was
five but the important part here
is this part here was responsive a lot
faster than this one so even when your
server can handle the L for instance the
cleanup the garbage collection and all
of that stuff will make your server uh
more unresponsive and it will take
longer for it to recover from that
bigger load than if you use cancellation
token so there's several different um
benefits to having cancellation
token and last common mistakes that I
saw and this one to be fair is very very
recent with ef core 7 actually now I
think they're calling it ef7 I'll need
to check the official name I think they
use sometimes EF core7 sometime ef7
sometime ef8 EF core 8 bit
mixed now
traditionally what we did if we wanted
to update uh say all of the employees
and here just just for fun what I did is
just swwa the first name and last name
uh of the employee imagine that we're
trying to just set everyone to be active
or we want to uh update something for
all of the
employees the way we need to do uh
nowadays the way we do it nowadays is
well we had to do until now was get all
of the employees we want to update and
then we need to do a full loop update
them or you know whatever we want to do
with the data we need to update need
them like that and what we results is
here is the initial query that gets all
of the data and over here is US updating
one employee at a
time which can take a while especially
if you have hundreds of employees
imagine if we're trying to update all 7
million
sales say that we want to just say okay
these 7 million sales are uh in that
text um text period and we just want to
take off that we have a that audited all
of them that will take a lot of time if
you do this
approach now what you can do now with ef
core 7 and EF core 8 you can now just uh
say uh execute update and then say set
this property to last name and last name
the first name now you could uh use an
actual string over here or your own
variable this is just me uh trying to
run a test that it can uh run
repeatedly uh but this what allows you
to do is if you already know how you're
going to update a specific record in the
database you no longer need to uh fetch
the data and then uh update it manually
in the net and then you save changes
which also is a lot more Cod and what is
also important here you can do we over
here and another thing is uh you can
also use uh the global query filters so
if you don't want to update um employees
that were self- deleted that is all
built in you don't have to think about
it it just works and if you wonder what
is tag withd if you want to know in sec
server um from where that request is
coming from this tag width uh is
included in the SQL query uh that means
that if you use SQL profile use
application insights seek uh console
logging file logging whatever and you're
logging uh your
queries you have now a string that you
can
directly um point to that specific code
that executes it and from EF core 7
onwards for the first time now you can
actually also tag with uh execute
updates and deletes which before wasn't
possible and the performance uh gains
here is this is only 23 um uh Records
but we still get fre times faster
performance now you can imagine how much
more that would be if we do saf for with
seven 7 million uh
Records all right we got 20 minutes so I
have time to talk about uh more advanced
stuff now uh we have done some of the
common mistakes that I have seen uh in
EF core and how many of you found so far
useful that the the
advice okay practically the entire
room now we're going to go a little bit
more advanced a little bit off track of
common
mistakes so the bonus tips that I have
is the other issues that I have seen
other horror
stories and one of them I seen it last
week like I have no words for it but
yeah um and it was kind of like this but
yeah uh
at least it was an old code
base um so what's happening here is this
happens more often that I uh want to
admit is when somebody does a two
list and then checks if it's more than
zero if you really want to do
inefficient but not too horrible at
least use first of default and then
check if it's not
null uh or just use do end that's even
better but yet I I actually seen
that and then we have uh get sales now
this is an interesting thing because I
didn't know why uh some people done that
until I was trying to talk to them and
what I realized is they didn't know that
you could use I quable to build a query
over time so what they did is they B
basically tried to fetch all of the data
that they know they they might need and
then they in memory filtered them out
right because they didn't know they can
just uh build the query over time and by
the way um some people use sale ID not
equals in the W CLW and then they use if
it's not uh not null then do this
comparison
which is perfectly
fine but if you want to maximize
performance you can also do this and
what that happens
is this condition never even reach a SQL
Server which gives you a slight
performance boost and another thing that
can also be a benefit is if this uh wake
Closs happens to have say um let's say
that it would be uh x. salesperson do
name equals to this name right if this
is in the Wake loss it will
implicitly join the salesperson table
but you don't want that to happen if you
not even want if you don't want to
filter um by a person's name but if you
do that baked it in that will always
happen happen so instead you can do this
and not have that condition sent to SQL
server at all and it will only to uh
join when you need
it all right how many of you know DB
context
pool only a handful of hands now DB
context pool is really cool now
Microsoft realized that most people
don't know about be context pool and
they moved a lot of the features uh to
the actual uh DB providers so DB
providers uh have connection pulled
behind the scenes what that means is
when you do a
query uh it makes a connection to SQL
server and when it's done with a SQL
Server it does not terminate the
connection it keeps that connection warm
so the next next time you ask something
uh from SQL Server you already have that
connection established so that's what
we're getting uh I think from efco 3.1
uh for free but what DB context allows
us on top of that is for the DB context
also be recycled they basically just
reset all of the DB context uh
properties variables so you you
basically get even more performance gain
and you get more memory uh efficiency
Microsoft also uh recommends this and
what it allows you to do is you can
become more scalable uh because the your
memory usage doesn't grow as fast with
theb context
pool one thing to uh just keep in mind
if anyone uses dependency injection on
DB context pool uh this may break it or
if you have anything uh that is stateful
now one trick that I do
is I use this and I hide the DB context
behind an
interface and I do manual resolving of
that interface by fetching the cell DB
and then
populating uh the injected services in
it that's one way I'm dealing with it so
that I can still get the DB context pool
features but if I have anything stateful
I can control it at the time I need uh
the recycle DB context just something to
keep in
mind now I have shown you get tweets
sorry a tag WID this is really cool
because you get it into the log um I
fortunately didn't have access to
VPN um and also my log AG was lost and I
couldn't get my battery running and all
of that stuff uh I actually have built
now reports where I can just have a
Columns of different tag width queries
and it gives me a chart which of the
queries are most
problematic and because I have this
comment over here I know exactly which
file uh to blame I can just say ah this
get tweets is uh okay but there's couple
of other queries I can just copy this
segment over here control shift F and I
get exactly to this query and then I can
address this query specifically this is
very important especially if you have
like random bursts of performance issues
and the performance issues are not too
clear uh with this you can try to
identify if SQL one of the SQL Server
queries is actually making the SQL
Server super busy uh and then you can
start diagnosing that particular query
from the
get-go also how many of you are using CH
GPT about a half of room three
quarters so there's a lot of tips I can
give you for ch P but the simplest one
for sake of time um if you in EF core
exp sorry you are an EF core expert and
clean code developer this part here is
quite nice you generally get slightly
better
code um and you can then write your uh
instructions over here you can
optionally paste DB context now your DB
context might be big so you can just uh
uh paste a snapshot of that just small
Snippets that are important for uh this
uh
prompt uh you might want to also add
entities sometimes it's not necessary to
have entities because uh it can deduce
from uh what you want and also the
return types because I I like the um I
like most of the data that I get from
the database to be already mapped
and what I have here is get all
employees details for each uh get
statistics on how many products they
sold how much they earned and list of
sales they did all
paginated now this is when you piece
together all of the things that I have
talked today this is not too difficult
to make but it may take an hour you know
you've write the thing you run it you
figure out that oh wait I actually uh
misunderstood how to do that or um you
know uh I need to join with this table
not with that and it take can take an
hour to build
this or you can just ask chat GPT and in
5 minutes you get a pretty good
code uh in this particular case in page
yeah so in this particular cage it
doesn't
actually do
counts but it would take you a minute to
just make a small refactor to also do
the counting but the cool thing is you
don't have to think about how to build
this thing here uh this thing here and
all of that stuff it just just does it
for you um so if you're looking for
great CH GPT
prompts and you're like you don't want
to remember lots and lots of things
this small snippet here is usually good
enough I would recommend that you run
three
times because some of the code might be
bad but in within three runs it usually
uh it usually gives you a pretty good
code and before we
end um this I have done this talk and
I've seen some people uh on YouTube
comments saying you shouldn't do
premature optimizations and stuff like
that uh and I added the segments just
for that
part and the reason why I wanted to give
this is to basically
explain when you should actually think
about performance because yes this talk
is focused a lot on
performance but it's focused on
performance on a very bad casis where
you can very clearly see hey it's not
just that the code looks a little bit
bad and doesn't really do what you
intended to do it actually has Major
Performance um uh side
effect but you know if you follow best
practices that's not premature
optimization that's just smart
programming um when you expect High
load you should talk with your product
owner and say hey this should be part of
acceptance criteria because if you know
there's going to be 7 million sales and
you don't have
pagination that's something that is
missing in the task you're
doing that's not trying to prematurely
optimize this is something missing in
the
specs uh and when there's something that
already C causes performance
issues you should at least make a
comment on it have it in your backlog
know that it
exists because a lot of time what
happens is people just accept that it's
low and then years pass along a lot of
data accumulates and at some point
there's a Tipping Point where the server
no longer can handle that much scale
maybe there's some added features or you
know you just start to um to reach the
maximum RAM and all of the sudden that
thing starts to become super
slow so what you want to do is
basically treat it as technical that
have it in the
backlog and never say we'll fix it later
with no action it is fine to say we'll
fix it later as long as you you comment
the code saying here is a problem we
need to fix it and then put it into
backlog too often I have seen where it's
like we'll fix it later and nothing
happened and then 2 years later it's
like oh yeah we said we're going to fix
that usually when it's way too late to
fix
it and also premature optimization is
not an excuse for bad code if you write
the bad
code and we all do I also
do you should at least mark it to be
fixed later there's no excuse to have a
bad code in your code base on a long
term yes there might be deadlines where
hey we will lose million dollars if this
does not get fixed today and you
basically don't do the best practices
that day but that means that you have a
task in your backlog that you fixed that
problem because you don't want to have a
problem that will haunt you sometimes 15
years later that's what I'm dealing with
today with current client problems done
5 10 years
ago so please fix
that and here are a couple of resources
you can find all of the uh tests that I
done in EF course sample stability and
performance uh if anyone wants to dig in
I actually done some SQL versus EF tests
and if you're interested in it's about
50% difference in EF course 6 so if
you which you know if you want to
optimize a quy that runs 80
milliseconds um reducing to 40
millisecond seconds that's not really a
huge gain especially because you lose on
maintainability
refactoring uh the code is a bit harder
to read and stuff like that but there
are some cases with that 50% means the
difference between running it for 30
seconds or 15 seconds that's where you
want to uh use say raw
SQL uh then we have also uh Microsoft
resources they done an amaz job with
this most of the tips are over there
when I started doing this almost none of
this was there so I'm really proud of
Microsoft to uh take initiative the only
problem very few know about this Ling
how many of you knew
that only a few
hint then we also have as ssw rules the
better Entity framework as well as link
uh and uh I also got an inspired a bit
from Nick chaps on how to do you know
the performance test and stuff like that
to show um actual impact of decisions so
it's not just use this code it's better
but saying hey use this code because
this stats over here this is this is
what happens if you don't and I really
like that uh
format so key
takeaway innumerable is very dangerous
use it only when it's intended to be
used when you use EF core for everything
else I inumerable is awesome just not
for EF
cor uh as not tracking you can get
almost free performance boost as long
the data that you're getting is supposed
to be read only if it's not you'll end
up with
bugs uh and simple codes can result in
better performance how many of you seen
the code from the bad code and good code
and
felt the more performing code is looks a
little bit
better we have a couple of hands but you
know even if it didn't look a bit uh a
bit better as long it's not worse than
the original and you're getting all of
these benefits uh it is a big win and I
really like to do queres that the
concise
performance uh and still gives me the
flexibility to refactor uh them and if I
need to Common them now I use Tag WID
which now serves not only for me to find
the queries in the SQL profiler but if I
had to do a more complex query it kind
of also s serves as a comment as well so
it now uh works as a double duty
you'll be able to find the presentation
over here uh I'll also make sure that uh
is on the
snack wait just a
second thank
[Applause]
you now we have five minutes for
questions
yes
question uh can can somebody bring a
mic I uh
[Music]
yeah so who do we need to call if we
have manual projection as no tracking as
no tracking so when you're doing manual
projection as no tracking is implicit
but there is a caveat um but there is a
caveat to the uh manual mapping um let
me try to find one where we have
uh I think it's no not that one uh come
on yeah so here so what happens is if we
do instead of sers first name if you do
s person equals x s
person now I
thought that if you don't do asot
tracking and you do
select um you good right but what I
learned is if you don't do as not
tracking over here all of this part here
would be
untracked but if you do sell person
equals X X Sil person this Sil person is
actually
tracked
yes uh which is why I ALS I usually add
as not tracking even if it's technically
not required just in case now in this
particular case yes asno tracking is a
bit
redundant but it might not be and if you
have a big developer team sometimes it
happens that they get entire table and
you know it's not necessarily wrong uh
especially if it's a list and they
basically need almost all of the data
and it's not something they return back
is just something they need to do for
processing uh it's fine um but yeah it's
basically causes a problem uh that it
can be tracked and you can accidentally
change s person when you didn't intend
to any other
questions uh we have over
there uh I want to know your uh view on
the lazy loading uh perspective like uh
when I'm doing many ques as you were
testing uh if we can benefit from this
CU I had some troubles with uh lazy
loading in the past yes and I want to
know your thoughts about this uh if it's
worth or not uh and if how how do you
see this like in a critical environment
uh of production so the question here is
how I look lazy loading uh yeah I want
to know if you if you think like is more
recommended to work with lazy loading or
if yeah yeah to answer question try not
to use lazy loading ever um in fact e
gets out of the way to make lazy adding
lazy loading a bit painful and I'm
grateful for
that um
because um we are currently migrating an
application if anyone is interested in a
lot more complex scenarios we moving
from Entity framework 6 to entity uh to
EF core
3.1 because we're moving from NET
Framework to net 8 but we cannot move 8
right away we can use fre one
first the original code had lazy loading
we had so many issues and when we fix up
the lazy
loading we haven't moved to net 8 yet
and people think we have because the
application is so much
faster and it was because there is no
way to know what thing is lazy loaded
and what is not now if you have to deal
with a um old uh
thing uh where tag withd um when you
have to deal with old uh
databases this thing here tag Rd can
help uh can save you because what
happens is if you have um sorry if you
have a lazy loading or if it has split
queries or things like
that that tag width will be in all of
the queries related to this so no matter
how many queries EF uh core will
generate as a result of that uh query
all of them will have the same tag
width and when you have multiple
queries with same tag width with same
comment over here but they're all
different you have a
problem it means that either you have
lazy loading or you have um uh query
splitting and include the sorry not
include the select kind of works as lazy
loading because it does implicitly uh
load uh data
I yeah I'll need to click through to
that go that but if anyone is interested
yeah when you do dot select that can be
your alternative to Lazy loading because
you can just specify all of the data you
want ahead of time uh and E EF core
figures out uh how to build a single
aquarium I hope that answers the
question very
good all right yeah we have one more
question and probably then we'll have to
go for break
yeah could you more information
queries uh so uh the question is about
split queries so the same way we do ASN
tracking we can also do uh s split query
now this I didn't include that because
usually this is a more complex problem
um where uh imagine you have a uh select
statement where you have a complex
mapping and that's the way Jo coins
Works say that you have one too many the
one say uh s person have say 100 S uh
sales what happens is that one uh salers
gets repeated 100
times because that one s person have 100
sales that's what you're getting that's
the raw data you're getting back from
SQL Server and EF cor basically hides
that fact um but what you can achieve
with if you just add uh as split query
is it can query separately uh the S
person and separately uh sales now in
this particular case the performance
gains are
minimum but for instance if you have a
slow connection or things like that you
can still benefit from lower package but
there are cases where you have complex
query where splitting the query have
massive uh massive improvements but
generally speaking you want to split
queres when you need to uh most of the
time because EF core is not the best
judge of on when to split the
query it's a little bit of Science and a
little bit of magic to figure out uh
went to spit
query thank you all right uh with that
if you have any questions I'll be around
and uh thank you for uh
[Applause]
listening